Until now we've only been building and
running pre-made images.
In this case, nginx.
It's time to learn how
to build our own images.
As a best practice, we're not
building our application with Docker.
No, instead, we're taking a binary that
could have come from our continuous
integration pipeline.
Then we use Docker to package our
application as a container image, and
to do that, we use a Dockerfile.
Dockerfiles are text documents that
contain all of the necessary steps for
building an image from the command line.
A Dockerfile,
when used with the Docker build command,
automates that process by executing
these command line instructions
to build the resulting image.
Let's look at one of ours.
Really quick aside,
Dockerfiles are always named Dockerfile.
That's because when the Docker
build command kicks off,
the command that uses our Docker file
to create an image, it also creates
a context of all the files in our
directory and its subdirectories.
The build daemon will then search for
a file called Dockerfile, although,
in practice it's best to just start
with an empty directory as context and
keep your Dockerfile there.
In that directory,
you only need to add the files necessary
for building your Docker image.
Okay, so let's pull up our Dockerfile.
After running the cat command you
can see the entire Dockerfile
for Hello image.
Each line in a Dockerfile
starts with a command.
This Dockerfile just uses four,
the FROM, MAINTINER, ADD, and
ENTRYPOINT commands.
By the way,
Dockerfiles can have comments, and
they start with a pound sign,
just like bash comments.
You can use comments to make your
life as the maintainer easier, and
to make it easier for the people
trying to decipher your Dockerfiles.
Quick question.
Do you think Kelsey didn't use comments
in writing this Dockerfile because
this is a really,
really simple Dockerfile?
Or because his comments are so
profound that many programmers
decide to retire after reading one?
You decide.
Moving on.
The first command in a Dockerfile
is the FROM command.
This tells Docker which base image
to build our new image on top of.
These days it's always best to
use Alpine Linux as your base.
Because it's small,
has a package manager,
and it allows you to debug
your containers in production.
Alpine is also used by default for
all the official Docker images.
We could optimize and
use the scratch space image, which
amounts to a no op, but then you lose
the ability to do basic debugging like
pinging from inside of your container.
Besides, if you're using
the same base image,
Docker only has to pull that once.
So we're only pulling that 5
megabyte cost once per machine.
Next we have the MAINTAINER command.
That just tells us that Kelsey is
the author and maintainer of this image.
Following that you'll see the ADD
command, which takes a file or
directory is from our host machine and
adds them to the file system of
the container at the specified location.
In this case, we're copying over
the hello bin from our continuous
integration or our go build
earlier into our container image.
Finally, ENTRYPOINT.
This let's our container
run as an executable.
So when our container starts,
it's going to run the hello app.
There are more commands you
can put into a Dockerfile and
you'll probably see some
of them in the wild.
Before our course,
this is everything you need to know.